[Music]
on the last video
oh the [ __ ] peed on me he says he peed
on me
so continues and said if it's time for
sleeping isn't it
sleepy tell them what's that do not [ __ ]
he's so calm right now where does he go
wrong with sleepy [ __ ] all the time
he shits all the time now listen when I
got a toe tiny oh oh oh he's [ __ ]
alright it's fine can you not [ __ ] you
[ __ ] toad
maybe he's [ __ ] out right now what do
you think sleeping oh no never mind he's
not [ __ ] at all right [ __ ] you then
how about I [ __ ] on you and see how that
feels
yeah you yeah I [ __ ] told him all
right so I announced a competition where
I would look at you your submissions to
the playing my game tuber simulator 10
million downloads 10 million downloads
keep spending money on the game I really
appreciate it Papa's gonna buy a new
Lambo let's start off okay first off we
have this it took me a while to
understand what's happening basically a
bunch of fangirls with Ainslie as a
bodyguard Aynsley I missed you thank you
now this is a really good room that
clearly they put a lot of effort in
where the [ __ ] is the desk anyway this
is must be Photoshop Maya Edgar play
slender dog that's the channel I would
like to watch Edgar Oh Oh sir Maya
Edgar Daniela fit I mean wolf sorry it's
kind of dumb but I really like it it's
very cute I really owe Felix life after
we announced this game
[Music]
for real though like compared to other
mobile games we're not making that much
money okay I've been really enjoying
seeing all the creations that's what I
said when we launched the game before we
launched the game I'm like I can't wait
to see what you bros are gonna make so
it's really cool to see I can be
creative ah my neck stretched oh [ __ ]
ah [ __ ] the [ __ ] hurt let's sleep
you're taking a [ __ ] right there but let
me tell you it does not look like that
it is not like that this is cool I like
this so Halloween is coming up so we're
gonna do a themed voting around
Halloween and a Halloween pack is coming
out as well but this is pretty cool
a lot of slippy shits going on which I
can fully understand because that son of
[ __ ] shits a lot it's not what I
expected when I bought a [ __ ] toad
let's just say that this is really cool
setup it's a cereal loominatee and I'm
in the middle but Raptor a strip club
with Edgar's DJ that's cool I like that
one
okay listen if you get this glitch just
change the room start tweeting it to me
and be like oh your game is broken all
you have to do is select the new [ __ ]
room stop bitching to me about it like
I'm tech support I'm not [ __ ] tech
support we don't even have tech support
[ __ ] we probably should have tech
support
listen just create a new room you're
fine alright oh and by the way while
we're on the topic I see so many people
being like your game is broken it has a
[ __ ] work and I can see that you have
a hacked version of the game are you
coming to me abandon [ __ ] up I know
if you hack the game okay don't try and
talk [ __ ] well that's that's alright
that's not the bet I've seen better rims
I'll write this one a 0.5 this is what
is cool they're playing hockey it's a
hockey match sleepy vs. Raptors see
that's create it I give you props for
that what the [ __ ] is with all the [ __ ]
oh my gosh you [ __ ] with the pants okay
never mind let's just move on
sleepywood [ __ ] wifeís all right well
someone likes boxes a bit much more
slippers [ __ ] Jesus Christ this as far
as your credit activity goes I mean it's
pretty [ __ ] accurate I'm not gonna
lie what do you think about this one
slippy I'm really scared I'm really
scared
I don't know if I'm scared of slippy at
this point or the fact that he's gonna
[ __ ] all over me has changed
it's no longer about nations ideologies
or ethnicity
it's an endless series of proxy battles
fought by mercenaries and machines war
and its consumption of life yeah I like
their setup this is a great [ __ ]
setup mate
I [ __ ] all over your desk I'm [ __ ]
right and [ __ ] now of course of
course my life is just a [ __ ] parody
of itself at this point what the [ __ ]
more slippy I guess you guys really like
slippy huh Wars changed I really like
him too I just wish he wouldn't [ __ ]
[ __ ] on me all the [ __ ] time this has
to be fake that's [ __ ] awesome if
that's real okay all right see this we
do you know how many [ __ ] hoops we
have to go through to make sure that the
game won't be censored because people
will make [ __ ] like this okay you're not
helping anyone
for [ __ ] sake not cool okay Irish
piece of [ __ ] Oh
oh boy I like that one all right sleepy
I don't want to terrorize him like we
got sleep before the memes but it's
still an animal and I respect that I
hope you guys don't think I'm
terrorizing Sleepy like we are really
taking care of an Irish piece of [ __ ]
now this is the best setup I have ever
seen in my [ __ ] life Jack I hope you
see this one and realize what an Irish a
I'm sorry I don't know why I'm so mean
to Jack Oh for [ __ ] [ __ ] you okay make a
game friends are better at it than he is
level third 50 kick the PJ level 36
Peter pie
or you think that's funny because
someone else is higher level I could
hack the game and make it battered PJ's
sheets okay that's all I'm gonna say PJ
you're a cheating cheater
Cheeta
do you guys hear that sleepy you
probably didn't hear that but he made a
weird noise
it's so cute I'll take it back I take it
back take it all back Thanks thank you
Michael what the actual [ __ ] now that's
a lot of barrels that's cool I can
appreciate that oh no Michael why why
all right this is just [ __ ]
disgusting I guess you guys like [ __ ] I
don't know what to tell you now for
[ __ ] sake
Edgar Lord of Death the undead
oh my god they built a chair out of
skulls that's [ __ ] awesome
now that's art this is cool I I mean
this is just a nice setup is it sleepy
army vs. parrot I don't know what's
happening all right but I like that
there seems to be a story that's a penis
[ __ ] oh I see what that is
hey you snuck that one in Netan yeah we
are adding tiny pixels so you can start
making pixel art in the game which I
think I'm really excited for you guys to
make a bunch of penises two different
Ford's versus each other can't versus
dog and sleepies filming it that's cool
like that's really creative but the [ __ ]
is this send Nick okay now it's gone too
far this game needs to be deleted what
does it say Trump 2016
whoa a shitty bro 4head a not so shitty
bro fish oh this is a duck pub that's so
cool you guys really like typing [ __ ] in
[ __ ] don't you man I am so impressed by
your breasts I didn't expect this cool
submissions I can't wait for the online
features to be available so you bros can
vote on the themes there's gonna be
themes daily themes and all that
[ __ ] basically there's way too many
people playing the game we had 10
million downloads which we never
expected myself and out of my team are
blown away we're so thrilled that you
bros enjoyed the game and it's so fun to
see you bros being creative with it I
think that's [ __ ] awesome I love
seeing this [ __ ] I'm gonna verify some
some of these as a reward for doing an
awesome job and I want to keep doing
that in the future so keep keep sending
your setups to me thank you so much for
watching I hope you enjoyed and if you
did leave a like your browser will keep
doing what you do and I will see you in
tomorrow's video professed
[Music]